[Music]
how're you doing today sir not bad at
all first of all thank you for coming by
my pleasure
I know you're a geek yes I am so let's
just jump right on in you have a Kong
Skull Island yes I do
this is besides getting a take chance to
get a picture taken like besides getting
chance a picture taken with Godzilla I
acted as King Kong I got the bike on
it's a lion statue so I'm all set
and I actually like this design better
than some of the older ones beforehand
so for me it was the original in this
version wasn't a big fan of the other
ones in between so buddy did you get to
cheat the line no no I was sitting right
there I felt like I found gold nobody
was going near Khan everybody's gonna
want the Godzilla stuff so Khan rules
yeah I I can't get out of this
convention without getting something
it's really difficult it's it's hard you
know for me the worst part is when I go
shopping for comics you know and I'm
always there looking and the things that
I'm looking for right now is so eclectic
and I collect very very particular
periods of time so like I love the stuff
from around the 70s to 72 it reminds me
when I first started reading comics
about what I couldn't afford Lilly
couldn't buy and now you're in a
position where you can buy it and I'm
like Jesus just a lot of money yeah
completely well that's the thing like I
I so I did the Russo brothers panel and
one of the reasons they went after
battle of the planets is cuz they loved
it as a kid right and so it's like it's
the same stuff it's like the stuff that
you wanted as a kid has you know the
nostalgia factor and you're like what
made it cool then is what makes it cool
now well it's interesting you say that
cuz that's an interesting part of the
problems problems of comics we have in
some ways in my opinion nostalgia is
driving all media right now it's what's
the pop culture phenomenon in and if
comic books or counterculture business
which it was for so long and if the
culture is nostalgia then what does
comics become you know you're hitting a
nail on that you know I mean and for us
when we look at comics you know we
should be working against the grain not
with the grain and how do we do that but
still be true to everything that we came
from but the other thing that to open
this door up the other thing is that you
have so many properties that have been
mined right and there have been so many
comic book shows on TV DC does an
amazing
on CW with all of their stuff it's
insane
right how many shows are thank you greg
berlanti right that guy's a genius but
what I'm saying is that like there's so
much out there that how do you shake it
to make it so it's fresh and new and not
been done before you just sat in a
meeting I had about five hours ago no
lie it's again it's about how do we
here's the hard part for us okay as
comics how do you stay relevant as a
comic book publisher in a world where
all media is pushing all your characters
in every other form the only way we stay
relevant ahead of them I don't we can't
be the position where the media is
determining the direction of the
characters so we have to be figuring out
where our Congress is gonna be five
years from now so when the media catches
up to us
we're the ones leading the charge and
creating the creative direction for all
these characters and stories completely
this leads me to what I was curious
about so where are you in the planning
stages on your day job uh we're pretty
far along right I'm happy to say and
that's the stuff that we do you know
it's it's always funny for me because
when I'm sitting around talking to the
talent or I'm sitting around talking to
folks where I am is two years ahead of
everybody where I'm thinking and what
we're working on so people are talking
to me about things that are happening
right now in my mind it's over and done
already I've already written it off oh
yeah yeah we've done that already and
like no it's never come out yet and I'm
like oh you're right and I keep on
forgetting about these things because
ultimately we're always trying to lay
the tracks in front of it so the Train
can really keep going to the best pace
possible sure what are you excited to
tease fans about what's coming in the
near vicinity I think what we're really
looking at is an exploration of the
generational aspect of the DC Universe I
think that's something that people
embrace and then I'm bored and I and I
said this before so I don't feel like
I'm giving too much away but one of the
things we've crafted is an overarching
timeline for the DC Universe something
that actually takes us from beginning to
end and explains the history of the DC
you we're all stories fall where
characters fall where they meet where
they didn't meet and a way to really
explain every major event and made you
think that matters in the DC Universe
and the timeline that we feel holds up
pretty well the reason why we did this
is because we want to create that base
of understanding of who our characters
are and where they came from and what
stories matter to them so when building
stories in the future
we knew what their past was and we knew
what we can work from from there okay I
think I asked you this last year with
Jim and asked you it again what the hell
do I need to do to get a Superman movie
oh that's a chimp question what was your
guy let me tell you something I don't
care I need I need your help to make
this happen
well you know what we feel the same way
you know and and the good part is right
now there's a lot of folks working very
hard to really execute the stories for
our characters best way possible
I'm the publishing guy so my job is to
stay in front of them Karen you know but
I'm hoping that they catch up and they
get a lot of good stuff going pretty
soon - what surprised you publishing
question what surprised you with sales
that you were not expecting and what was
a little bit disappointing that you
thought was better than what the sales
reflected um the two things that I
surprised me deceased which it was
really just a more fun just a silly
concept that wound up exploding or all
over the place where our characters are
all zombies you know you think that
craze is over and you put a bunch of DC
characters as zombies out there and we
sell like crazy but the one that was
very exciting to see was neomi somehow
that book caught on fire and whether
it's speculators or whatever but that
book started to really get some traction
and because of that I feel there's some
real potential out there for freshness
and new ideas right how quickly okay
let's talk about the DC as zombies so
you put that out all of a sudden gets
this buzz and people are buying it what
is like what is it like like sort of the
next day in the meeting room
where you're like okay wait a minute we
have something here how quickly can we
pivot to embrace what the fans are
responding to this - things you - things
you oh you know how do we make sure we
get the most out of what's going on
right now and is there something else
out there but let's not force it because
what happens for us is that if you come
out with another project and it doesn't
work well people remember it not being
successful then the success you had so a
lot of times what I try to do is find a
way to say if there's a natural
follow-up to this explore it build it
and let's go for it but if it's
something you're forcing out the door
just to try to make a couple of bucks
more let's not bother sure with first
printing reprints how do you feel as a
publisher and as a collector when you do
like the you know the second
third printing alt covers all that stuff
um it's an interesting question because
you know when we launch new books if I
have something that I feel is gonna be
important to the DC Universe it's gonna
make a long time stand there I I get
very frustrated about putting full
alternate covers on it because I try to
look at what's the one cover that people
hold up as the start of the series this
is the introductory character this is
the cover that matters most and so
that's one of the things I'm looking at
all the time and and ultimately though I
do know that there is a collector's
market out there and we've changed our
programs when it comes to the variant
covers we actually have created covers
that are on a better cardstock and uh
priced on the creators on them on the
artists that people actually collect on
a much greater sense because the books
hold up better and if they're binding
for the art then we want to make sure
that presents itself properly me I'm
still worried about making sure people
are reading the books and expanding the
audience anything we could do expand the
audience is what I'm really looking for
right now sure um I think that the
listen I'm a big fan of comic book
covers just like everybody else because
ultimately that's like a cool cover as a
cool cover like I think about that
MacFarlane Batman that's now that statue
you know was revealed here I think he
did three issues of Batman and yet that
has stood the test of time you know it's
just it's crazy so for you as a
publisher have you ever said yeah this
cover how many times do you say this
cover is not gonna cut it or you know
what I mean like because that's what
people look at that's the first thing
more times than you know because the
problem is when you have so many
different artists coming on to the
characters they all come from the same
pose how many times am I gonna see
Batman standing on a gargoyle how many
times I'm gonna see the Justice League
coming rushing at me how many times am I
gonna see the characters standing Riegel
side-by-side shoulders shoulder back to
back every character every artist has
his interpretation of that shot but you
have to be judicious about how you use
them because ultimately you get very
repetitious on the stands and one of my
fears were and I sat down and talked to
these guys about it when we were doing
the double ships when you double
shipping books and you're putting two
covers on every book that's four covers
of the same character in a very short
period of time so each one of us should
feel unique in its own way shape and
form so we have one set of rules that
apply to the main cover which are more
story based and for the more art centric
covers we ask them to push it a little
more stylistically so it's
clear that it's being more artist-driven
than it is being driven on ragazza story
sure I think I'm gonna bring Jack Kirby
into this for a second I think about
some of the panels that he created these
iconic things that have stood the test
of time talk a little bit about how much
you guys are trying to I don't know I
don't want to say break the rules that
currently exist in the comic form but
like do you know what I mean like trying
to push the boundary forward while also
still keeping the the what people love
and like here's okay so that's an
interesting question and it's taken on a
new form I have people breaking rules
they don't even know what the rules are
anymore so what's happened is that
people are doing things following other
people who broke rules and using those
broken rules as the new established norm
and when you're doing that and you know
don't know what you're basing it on it
loses his import and its weight so for
us we have to remind people what you're
doing and what you're basing this on so
therefore they have a clear
understanding of where they're coming
from and then if they want to break the
rules then we're all for it but you got
to know what rule you're breaking first
before you break it
completely who is I'm gonna I'm gonna
ask you to put your favorite anchor
right now oh it's a great question Kevin
Nolan okay I've no there's no right or
wrong I know that I know that it's an
interesting question to any Mickey
sudden some beautiful work for us I'm
watching what he's doing on John Romita
on the Superman Year one book and it
really brought a different weight in
life and and I loves John stuff and I
love with him working with Klaus Janson
another great anchor it was fun to see
somebody else come aboard and find a
different interpretation the same artist
sure what do you think I think it's my
last question cuz I'm gonna be out of
time what do you think where is DC in
three or four years where do you hope it
is where I hope it is is that it's a
wildly diverse line of product gearing
to a widely diverse audience sure okay
and what I mean by that you see the
makings of it right now you see us
pushing into the young adult market with
our young adult books at middle reader
books we have a great success on the
Raven book that just came out from kami
Garcia and Gabriel piccolo book is
actually catching fire in a way that we
were hoping could happen but actually
surprised it did happen
and then we're gonna bring a more
focused ECU lining that I feel it's a
better sense of the shared universe
we're gonna continue to grow the mature
material so you get that sense of else
words but all these great morality plays
of our characters really perform
brilliantly in and things that could
stand alone and help rebuild our
collected editions line and then also
we're looking at the giants that we've
created and with the giants we're
looking as classic interpretations of
our characters in a way that even the
most casual fan can understand so that
helps broaden it out so somebody just
wanting to understand who characters are
you go to those books then on top of
that we have not enough plans right now
right though but that's but the idea is
that one size doesn't fit all completely
and it's even more important that not
just one story can be just adapted into
multiple formats and make it work we
have to create stories for different
audiences in different formats to make
sure we're reaching everybody possible
yeah listen I have a million other
things but I'm gonna stop there and say
Brian till next comic-con but enjoy your
Kong
I am super jealous and thank you for
stopping by and next comic card you
asked been a question about where this
going again yes thank you you got it